well this is oh i do it's dio
god
he's he he is going through like every
part he's he's actually going to lose
because i was points for getting all the
same right
that's the road roller one i thought
this was too good not to get and it
would look sick on the shelf yeah i
remember which way it goes yeah it's
this way
yeah and where does this hand go like
here at the back isn't it
oh yeah it's like that yeah yeah yeah so
that looks pretty cool actually i
thought it would look really cute on the
shelf to have a road i feel like i feel
like so cute i feel like conor's just
rebuilding his set from home right yeah
these actually i wish i had at home
if you guys don't want to have them on
the set i'll gladly take care of them i
thought well that's just so sick like oh
it's so cool that's pretty simple that's
really nice oh there he goes well it
goes to here maybe he wants to ride it
maybe he wants to ride
i got that i gotta how many more things
do you have gone i have one more i
should show you some more keep going
i got another one oh my god
you don't know if you buy duplicates you
lose points all right uh yeah i know but
only one point right
wait he's got three deals he's got three
dios he's got three tiers yeah but
it's the same character so there's only
one duplicate right
is that is it how it works i think it
should work in even numbers yeah so it
goes like two four six you know yeah so
if you bought one more dictatorial yeah
yeah so if you buy one more d or figure
then that's two points you know i i
bought sick figures because they were
sick you know they were sick nasty
figures and this one is like a big
chunky boy
connor finds a jojo figure that's a sick
figure that's a sick figure that's a
chunky deal jesus
that looks like it's from the uh 90s
yeah yeah that's right a lot of these
have looks like that that face is
definitely like i remember this scene
from the 90s yeah that's what i went for
exactly yeah yeah you don't often see
the older ova figures but i feel like
they've got a nicer build quality in
some ways mm-hmm
this is cause it's because like it was
like jojo wasn't mainstream when the 90s
okay came out yeah exactly oh [ __ ] no no
it's so big i just
couldn't help myself big boy knocked
over another big boy
oh [ __ ] this is [ __ ] damn that's a
that's a chunky boy just as a note none
of these our uh our knives all of these
are ashley's knives
knife connoisseurs so i don't know why
you own all of these knives not a knife
that's a kunai dude
so that's the deal nice i think that's
pretty [ __ ] that's really cool that's
really really what you're saying i think
it's this one that's a really cool
figure which life would it be i don't
[ __ ] know i hate these stands
which one is it do we know just give it
a base yeah yeah
it's his stand
that's a jojo reference
gone what's your final figure my final
one all right all right
gentlemen
as joey has just shown you've heard
of goku black
[Music]
i did you did not get that thing well
let me introduce you to
you did not
you did not get that figure oh you
didn't get that figure let me introduce
you to
black goku
i was hoping one of you would have
bought this not glad
does it matter tell me how much it was
it was
uh
how much was this
oh my god those are 60
no that was 60 bucks that was 60 bucks
what a [ __ ] steal what went wrong
who made this i think i think someone at
the factory [ __ ] up and they clearly
forgot to like paint it
who's trying to sell an unfinished
figure it's like somebody like somebody
in the factory was like all right we've
got the model down perfect uh now we
just got to apply pain and then there's
like uh it's going out
like the detail is really really good
but he's just like he's just sunburned
what happened
sunburn
you mean he like ran into the sun then
yeah probably but like he's a charred
that is that actually looks really cool
though it does it does is this like a
character in dragon ball fighterz that
hasn't been released yet
we've been waiting for the final boss
it's like a dark link right yeah
so i don't know i just saw that and i'm
just like i just need to buy this just
so i can say what the [ __ ] happens you
know that i mean to be fair that's
actually really cool it's really cool
yeah but uh
wait hold on do i lose a point because
we both got go i guess
great
awesome after all that convincing i
tried to do
and i just lose the point
all right so my second challenge at a
stop was to get a figure from an anime
that i ever recently wait wait wait but
you you got goku black right no no no no
no no no no no no that they're
this is actually the goku that goku
black kills
the same character they both lose this
is what happens when
i i actually think canonically
yeah check this is is that because
that's just regular goku that's just
painted if it was like a reskin if i got
like super saiyan goku or something the
viewers they would say goku is that goku
black no no no no no no
no thank you what do you mean you guess
there's no use the same character not
the same guy where's his name it's goku
no no it's black goku
i bought super saiyan goku black no no
it's goku oh no he has another [ __ ]
name he has another name
oh zamasu zamasu yeah no no it's a
different character it's a different
character
it's literally a different character
thank you thank you thank you
thank you dragon ball super for being
stupid we should ask twitter a poll take
a picture they'll say that it's the same
character no
yeah exactly yeah because you know if
the viewers watch this the videos
you know you know you know i i
if if it was if we are asking dragon
ball fans
no it's the same all right my second
challenge at a stop was to get a figure
from an anime that i have recently
watched so nothing
see
so what did we count as recently again
three months you said three months right
yeah yeah which means that it has to be
either from this season or at least last
season right that's three months we can
you could have watched an old anime
right
well you know i think you forget there's
one very very very popular anime this
season that has actually come out that i
did actually watch but i didn't watch it
this season i watched it quite a while
ago
oh my god
do you guys know that this doesn't count
that doesn't that doesn't count excuse
me you go on to mao you look up anime of
this season uh i'm pretty sure demon
slayer mugen okay okay wait wait wait
wait wait actually comes out watch it
within the past three months yeah yeah
what did you why we watched it no you
haven't have you yeah i have no you
haven't [ __ ] you no you [ __ ] haven't
wait for what for what reason have you
re-watched it because i thought it was a
good movie no you have not watched it
you have not look i'm sorry you guys
said look on mal and if it's from this
season or last season then it counts you
must have watched it within the past
three months
what have you what it said whatever you
wanted watched it within the past three
what have you watched in the past three
months
[ __ ] nothing
obviously that's why i picked this
it's from this season you guys said it
needed to be from at least
three months
three months it came out within the past
three months you have to have watched it
in the last came out within the past
three months i'm sorry i saw it earlier
yeah but it came out in the last three
months recently i don't care it came out
no we we literally we literally picked
that challenge beforehand because we
knew it would [ __ ] you over if you got
it and you you somehow got it i'm i'm
saying if i get the most expensive
figure challenge joey then you're going
to take the l on this one i'm sorry man
you clearly took the l in the most
expensive one
i l you literally said that came out
within the last three months this came
out within the last three months no we
said watching what we probably would
have never said what is the matter what
is the exact wording of the challenge
figure from an anime that you've
recently watched
recently
recently were you [ __ ] making up this
mouth [ __ ] yeah i might as well not have
eyes either because i clearly didn't
watch anything in the past three months
you guys knew that
obviously so i obviously made the
[ __ ] rules well
it's not our fault
it's not my fault anime has been mid as
[ __ ] this year
i know what an anime you watched
recently what made an abyss you
re-watched it no the movie uh yeah you
re-watched made in abyss right that
didn't come out in the last three months
no no yeah it literally doesn't say come
out in the past three months yeah it
said recently right within the past
three that is not recent yeah but you
re-watched it
have you watched okay so hold on what
was this supposed to be
it needed to be it needed to have come
out in the last three months yeah you
said no it needed you needed to have
watched it in the last no no no i have
video proof you said it needed to have
come out in the last three years when
you provide that
when you when you provide video proof
it's live right now it's this episode
i don't see the video proof right now so
i guess we'll have to uh wait for the
day but this came out in the last three
months all right all right ashley how
how many contentious points do we have
now we have the jones
we we have the goku black i think most
of the points are content all right i i
think we might need to uh wait off uh
well and we might need to wait off uh to
let the audience decide some of these
points and then we can do like the
forfeit well later then do you know our
audience they're gonna do everything
they can to [ __ ] us over well that's
it's it's
they're not gonna give us the point it
might as well be zero points look look
audience we're gonna make a poll on
reddit and uh we're gonna we're gonna
that's the worst idea we're gonna ask
you this is literally the worst idea
i've ever heard